[Music]
many businesses have invested large
amounts of time and money in on-premise
security policies and controls when you
work with our open ecosystem of
technology partners you're able to take
your existing controls into the cloud
and mitigate threats more effectively to
discuss this further I have with me
vineet Bonn head of security technology
partnerships at Google cloud Adam Geller
vice president of product management at
Palo Alto Networks and Ming Chang cloud
security awareness lead at sa P thanks
fellas for coming Vineet why don't you
talk a little bit about Google clouds
philosophy when it comes to partnering
technology partners and security sure
Google's philosophy is to create an open
ecosystem of partners so we can meet
customers where they are in their
journey to migration in cloud so
customers would have a choice of using
Google technology and combine that with
best of breed security partnerships so
it will also help in Google and partners
working closer together in the future to
create the next generation of security
products that'll be lot more easier and
automated than what customers are used
to having today ok so an easier journey
in the future meet them where they are
take them forward Adam as one of the
partners in the ecosystem but also a
strong leader in security for many years
talk a little bit about how customers
are viewing the cloud and how it might
have been changing over the past couple
of years sure so when a lot of our
customers started making the cloud
journey to be honest security wasn't
their top priority their major focus was
speed and time to market for the
applications they were building and to a
lesser extent possibility of maybe cost
savings for a different method for
deploying their applications but those
apps really were focused typically on
development and test workloads so the
the emphasis from from security
standpoint was a little bit lower fast
forward to where we are today and
there's no question the cloud is used
for very advanced production workloads
with high quality and very sensitive
data so as you'd expect what's moved
along with that is the emphasis on
enterprise class security and really
bringing along
the concepts that were critical in an
enterprise data center making sure those
can still be applied in the cloud but
now apply them in a different way based
on the capabilities of the cloud
environment op you there and talk a bit
about the what the key concepts would be
and how they're reflected in products or
services were offering sure so
fundamentally if your objective as an
organization is to prevent a successful
attack you need to think about four
things you need to be able to have full
visibility and we're talking mostly
about network security right now but
this really applies broadly across the
security landscape for an organization
so it's four things it's complete
visibility it's the capability to reduce
an attack surface area to a meaningful
scope of work it's to be able to
successfully prevent any known attack
you should be able to prevent it
outright so you don't have to think
about it and then for things that are
truly unique and unknown or novel
they've never been seen before you need
to be able to detect and prevent it very
quickly and turn that time around so
that it becomes something that you've
known already and then you can deal with
okay and so those four areas travel with
the customer those concepts those
practices travel with the customer into
the cloud how do things change the
number of touch points the level of
compute and how do you speak to that in
the products and services you're
offering sure so when we work with
Google cloud platform it's it's the
application of those four principles
they change because the environment
necessarily is different than what the
enterprise controls themselves in their
traditional data center so in Google we
have the opportunity to integrate in
from a networking standpoint differently
from a context sharing information that
we learn that we can share with the
cloud platform and what the cloud
platform can share with us and that all
adds up to a much more automated and
scalable solution that looks very
different operationally from what people
have done traditionally in their data
centers I mean let me turn to you
because s AP has relationships going
back years and in some case decades with
thousands of companies around the world
really reshaping the way things are
manufactured finance distribution of
goods all sorts of things how are the
customers viewing security in the cloud
and
the move to the cloud particularly since
we've started this deep relationship
with Google in the past year yeah
security definitely top of the concern
but also how to manage the security
risks as well as meet the regulatory
requirements and to be in a competitive
market to succeed customer has the
choice to move to cloud which is the
best choice so that have about the
scalability the flexibility as well as
the cost and security embedded to it
what is the priority they have where
security is concerned protection of data
threat vector changing contexts or
styles of work what do you see sure
definitely the security the application
security the platform that runs need to
be secure the visibility that they need
to have to manage those security as well
as how are we how are they going to meet
the regulatory requirements they need to
provide reports requirements visibility
to whoever they need to respond to I
want to ask you all a little bit about
the future and I'll start with you Ming
where do you see the partnership going
in terms of what sa P wants to deliver
to its customers sure the partnership is
great s AP and Google are able to create
data custodian a solution which can
provide a customer ability to set up the
controls that they need as well as the
visibility with the Google's highly
secure public cloud and sa piece
knowledge and experience on managing the
business processes we can make the
customers exceed when they are in the
competitive environment okay Adam so
where I see this going is an evolution
from sort of the basic basic
integrations and basic starting point of
how do I do something similar to what I
had in my enterprise data center to how
I do it much more natively and much more
integrated in with the fabric that
Google cloud platform is providing and
that typically will hit in areas of
automation and scale again and it's
automation from the deployment
standpoint and infrastructure but also
then the automation
and how I process and respond to actual
security events and alerts and Vinnie
where do you see partnership going
inside Google cloud so our vision is to
work along with best-of-breed partners
like ACP and Palo Alto and make security
as a driver for migration to the cloud
so as companies are evaluating their
migration to the cloud they can see
security posture in the cloud that
Google has developed with their own
technology combined with best-of-breed
partners is so much better than what
they could get in an on-premise
deployment very helpful gentlemen thank
you very much thank you thank you